die flüchtlinge gegen soldaten eine
humanitäre katastrophe auch wirklich
allen ebenen es gibt viele verletzte und
auch einen toten migranten bewaffnen
sich mit draht schneidern und steinen
versuchen mit aller gewalt nach polen
also in die eu zu kommen ihnen gegenüber
soldaten sie setzen blendgranaten und
wasserwerfern verteidigen die grenze und
ein polizist wird dabei auch schwer
verletzt schädelbruch lautet die
diagnose
doch der ansturm erlebt im großen und
ganzen liegt es tauchen immer mehr
menschen am grenzzaun auf verzweifelte
frauen und kinder und das alles bei
temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt
bei uns im studio ist peter tiede peter
jetzt könnte man ein bisschen hoffnung
haben die bundeskanzlerin hat mit
lukaschenko den weißrussischen diktator
telefoniert 50 minuten lang angeblich
das ist schon eine ungewöhnliche
maßnahme mit auch vielleicht ein
umstrittener maßnahme mit lukaschenko
direkt zu telefonieren worum ging es in
dem gespräch du hast informationen
darüber also ist eine heikle mission
weil eigentlich spricht man mit herrn
lukaschenko erste offizielle titel war
er wird ja nicht präsident genannt herr
lukas schenkel mit ihm spricht man nicht
erst persona non grata wir sind
diplomatenkreisen heißt also jetzt eine
unperson frau merkel hat es trotzdem
getan etwas mehr als 50 minuten hat sie
mit ihm gesprochen lukaschenko hat das
bier probiert was er vorher schon gesagt
hat oder seine vorher schon versucht hat
was auch moskau schon probiert hat was
putins außenminister da worauf auch
gefordert hat indem ich die aufhebung
von sanktionen und dann ganz zynisch
nach dem motto ihr habt doch damals der
türkei auch geholfen ihr habt doch der
türkei geld gegeben damit die
flüchtlinge zurück hält das macht doch
jetzt mal mit lukaschenko auch also nach
dem motto die türkei damals hat euch
geholfen jetzt hilft ihr auch dem auch
lukaschenko natürlich vieles war die
türkei hatte 2015 drei millionen
flüchtlinge im land hat man nicht geholt
ich sind einfach gekommen jetzt lukas
schenkel hat die leute geholt und das
hat nur geschenke auch in dem telefonat
nach unseren informationen versucht bei
frau merkel durchzusetzen da ist sie
hart geblieben man hat sich nach unseren
informationen dann darauf geeinigt dass
frau merkel mit den europe mit den
europäischen staatschef jetzt bespricht
obmann
härtefallregelung macht also lukas
schenkel wollte 50 50 machen die hälfte
der flüchtlinge ins land geholt sollten
nach europa und die andere hälfte sei er
bereit wieder auszufliegen das hat die
kanzlerin nicht angenommen sie ist aber
war aber nach unseren informationen
bereit über härtefälle zu reden also
über einen über familien über frauen mit
kindern dass man die vielleicht nimmt
die über den grenzzaun lässt und dann
nach deutschland und woanders hin
bericht bringt sie ist heute auch wenn
deutsche städtetag sie trifft sich heute
ganz routinemäßig mit dem
oberbürgermeister erfurts das ist der
chef des deutschen städtetages da wird
am rande auch darüber gesprochen werden
und als zweites was wir erfahren haben
wo man noch gesprochen hat ist dass man
finanzhilfen irgendwie nach belarus
bringen könnte wahrscheinlich über ngo s
nicht über direktzahlungen aber
finanzhilfen für den bau von
notunterkünften
pluschenko argumentiert dass er opfer
einer flüchtlingswelle ist und das auch
aus afghanistan mehr flüchtlinge kommen
könnten in seinem land das ist
eigentlich nur eine versteckte drohung
weil die flüchtlingen die jetzt da sind
hat er sich auch geholt vorerst niemand
auf die idee gekommen über weißrussland
1 fliegen um nach deutschland zu kommen
die route hat er selber zusammen mit
seinem partner mit wladimir putin
geschaffen und dann trotzdem droht er da
durch die hintertür nochmal also wir
müssen hier flüchtlingsunterkünfte
bauern bald kommen mir mehr aus
afghanistan darüber informiert frau
merkel jetzt gerade also jetzt im seit
gestern abend auch die anderen
europäischen staatschefs das ist schon
eine sehr heikle mission also man
spricht eigentlich nicht mit ich mit
jemand darf ihnen auch nicht anerkennen
er möchte anerkannt werden er hat das
auch in dem telefonat klar gemacht ihr
möchte als als präsident anerkannt
werden wir ändern uns mal zurück er hat
die wahl gestohlen die rechtmäßige
präsident in also gewählt ist yanofsky
und er möchte quasi als präsident
anerkannt werden und er möchte dass die
sanktionen aufgehoben werden und das ist
natürlich eine dreiste forderung der
darf man schlicht nicht nachkommen sagen
wir mal so wenn frau merkel
erfolg hat mit der mission wenn
lukaschenko in den nächsten tagen wird
nicht dafür sorgt dass die flüchtlinge
sich von der grenze zurückziehen die
meisten lager sind leer sich von der
grenze zurückziehen und wenn er wirklich
dafür sorgt dass die auch zurück fliegen
dürfen und auch die tickets bezahlt
bekommen dürfen nicht vergessen die
haben ja alle nicht sonderlich viel geld
die haben ihr geld schon investiert was
sie auch kostenlos zurückgeflogen werden
dann hat die mission erfolg wenn nicht
nicht schieben gelaufen also eine sehr
gute idee was herum anderem irakischen
fernsehen gemacht hat das wird
wahrscheinlich
effekt haben oder was ist deine meinung
man muss abwarten aber es ist besser als
gar nichts zum zu machen und im
nord-irak unser kollege bernd witzel der
sich in der gegend gut auskennt sagte
verhindern es ist ein bisschen heikel
weil die basalen die leute sind ja auch
die die jetzt quasi mit dafür gesorgt
haben dass sie dahin sind weiß man nicht
genau aber es ist besser als gar nicht
zum zu machen und es ist eine gute idee
zu der propaganda die aus moskau und aus
weißrussland in diesen gegenden dann
gemacht wurde agitation entgegen zu
setzen wäre vielleicht auch eine idee
die beispielsweise einen außenminister
machen könnte könnte genauso gute oder
frau merkel selber im prinzip im
irakischen im syrischen und in den
anderen ländern fernsehen sprechen auf
die idee hätte man kommen können und man
kann auch tatsächlich solche clips
machen und in sozialen medien in den
ländern entsprechend vertont oder
untertitel verbreiten um die leute
einfach aufzuklären